as davin concluded of the talks between
the taliban and representatives from
afghanistan a number of issues were
discussed
including the release of prisoners
delisting from united nations list there
was talk about amending the constitution
an
all-inclusive government and a political
roadmap towards peace
the taliban insisting that before there
is a discussion
about a ceasefire across afghanistan
there needs to be
an inclusive government which represents
all uh
segments of the afghan society not
specifying how they're going to achieve
it
but wanting that as the first step but
they've also been saying that because
such a high power delegation has come to
the qatari capital they're willing to
discuss
everything that they are bringing to the
table we hope
and we want and we expect that
they should have brought something to
give momentum
and on our side we are ready to show
flexibility
and our aim is clear and that is
to have an islamic advanced exclusive
government in place
in afghanistan and put an end to this
phase
of fighting and enter a new pace
which will be a peace and good for every
abraham
as the taliban discussed peace the
situation on the ground in afghanistan
has been deteriorating
there are people who have been
expressing their concerns
about how taliban have been taking not
just district but provincial capitals
as well as coming towards the capital
kabul as well we asked the afghan
minister for peace
about what his uh hope is from this
level of talks as
they're definitely not going to be
conclusive in 48 hours
but he thinks that he what he wants the
other side to realize is that there is
no
uh there's no solution by force to
afghanistan's problems
and the only way ahead is through
negotiations
we have to keep the door of the
negotiation
open because the solution to the
conflict
is not violence so the solution
is actually a meaningful negotiation to
be very frank with you we've been
quite flexible and also tolerant
since the start of the talks
so what's important is that i call upon
the taliban
to show the same flexibility and same
understanding
that they need to understand that
to have the intention of taking
afghanistan by force is not going to
[Music]
work
you